two creeks here I was told to give you a
card if you guys show up cool that's
wing yeah
TransCanada yeah so you guys know you
guys don't have permission to be here
right
um I'm not aware of traditional just
serious energy if you would like a
spirit will leave no TransCanada has
already been warned right equipment will
be confiscated if you guys return
and again safe
the pipelines are trying to go right
through for the salmon spawn and that's
where we decided to put the action camp
in last year we put a cabin right smack
in a way of the pipeline so that they
would not go through and we just
deliriously washer we fenced it off
because we saw ribbons in there for
drill pads for them to start do test
drills so they can drill a pipe right
under the river there we've been hearing
all the media of all these pipes
breaking and waterways getting damaged
and we just not going to accept that
risk because we don't want to be 25
years 10 years down the road telling our
kids oh we used to hunt moose here and
waste the fish we've never seated or
surrendered or lands to anybody here
there's no treaty there's no
relationship built with any government
in the past none of our people signed
anything to let them make decisions and
on our territory
tomorrow morning at 3:00 we may see some
trucks attempting to get through to log
the right-of-way we're gonna have to
differentiate them so we're going to go
through all the peaceful avenues we can
but a way of a warrior is you go through
expand all peaceful avenues first and
when all those fail it's war that is the
way of the warrior
we're worried we put this cabin right in
root of the PTP and Everidge pipeline
GPS route that's where this cabin sits
now and they have now since moved it
upstream boat five kilometers no it's a
half a kilometer out of two kilometers
away by way of them actually amending
their their project and changing the
location of the cross and we decided to
start building a more infrastructure in
their way again so we did a call for
people to come on assistance and the
construction of a pit house and if in
Tosa went directly in the path of the
Pacific trails pipeline deliberately
because specific trails was farther
along than the rest of the pipeline's
and their permitting processes
you
this is the black haters dream those
have been doing it for a while yeah some
people build platforms and sleeping
dragons I build a whole bug in I'll
build a blockade it's not just a
blockade it's a it's also a living it's
a real dwelling this is a part of the
decolonization and returning to the land
and return it to the always the told a
sign free to talk talks about all the
time but you still have to nail
something to hold that together right
we've been living here for two years and
we've already been bought up culturally
touched I and I are both culturally
brought up and we are living culturally
now we get all our own meats and we
gather up berries and we make sure we
put away enough food the last of the
whole winter and the shear I put away a
hundred fish so I guard all that famine
you don't ever tail moves head cheese
your ribs I'm going to deer me some told
me a lot of salmon some groundhog
berries that we did last season so
fairies huckleberries a lot of jam this
is the deer we got this sure some of its
gross this all is in case they do block
us because there's been threats they're
gonna block us from the other end that's
why we're preparing food Weiss we have
food cache all over the territory our
people have had enough and we're not
going to just stand here and take the
bullying and take it without a fight
where we've had enough of the spoiled
brats stealing off our lands and not
accepting no for an answer and we're
going to be the stern parents and say no
you're not coming in
could be on TransCanada because they're
the ones that didn't submit their route
through here yet but I know Enbridge was
come in wanted to come in here specific
trails on this side and we did know
where TransCanada wanted to go so this
is probably TransCanada crew coming back
in they did put up stakes in here before
reroute the ball out a couple years ago
well three years ago we came out tormal
out but this whole area between here and
the truck that valley that's where they
want to run all the pipeline stir
there's no freakin American that any of
those guys in
we don't have a toxic sign on it on the
side here you do identify this petroleum
there's no toxics I go into a hospital
and you throw a klutz
you put them in a container that has a
toxic time that's right into wash and
the container here that we have for them
but even with that being here people
shouldn't be able to click it
Thank You Pedro some surprising guys
have it open but there was a regulatory
process that we found
federal government has now Minnesota
proceed so what have we told you that
the federal government doesn't have
jurisdiction on our territories 50% of
your proposed project is on with Sudan
character all the hereditary Chiefs that
have said hundred percent know for this
project we we have the final site not
the federal government not the
provincial government well we were I
hear what you're saying and we're
following the like I said the regulatory
process that we have in front of us and
we can talk to you about some of the
conditions that include environmental
monitoring a lot of surveys
we can talk to both and what have we
told you we know that's and it
doesn't work we look at the state of our
whole planet what it's in and they're
all our waters are being destroyed the
air is destroyed all the trees are being
destroyed you can't continue to bulldoze
over my people
our lands our final say no pipelines
will be coming on our lives
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation available in
your app store now